long hair was not an option for Parisa
Louis who spent her childhood in Iran
[Applause]
others to protest against the Iranian
government and its strict laws on head
coverings I remember when I was in Iran
I
a mom used to keep my hair pretty short
so that I could go out as a boy so my I
even had a boy Nick's nickname so that
my brother used to call me by that
nickname so that I could go out without
the hijab because my mom just refused to
put a headscarf on a little girl it was
just ridiculous
thousands rallied here on Trafalgar
Square calling for tougher action
against Iran
women
least that we deserve it's sad that it's
something that we have to fight for that
people are being killed for but it's
it's what we deserve the protests have
entered a sixth week not just here in
London but in other cities and of course
in Iran they may not be close to
toppling the regime there but this is
seen as the boldest challenge to Iran's
clerical leaders since the 1979
Revolution
in cities across the world protesters
want to change
in Iran they're cleaning up after
another demonstration turned ugly
57 people were arrested after a rally in
zahidan yesterday it comes as Amnesty
International said 66 people were killed
in the province in a violent Crackdown
last month
a number some say is growing the
unprecedented brutality is not
um people are not stopping from
protesting and we're expecting more
internet disruptions already there's
difficulty reaching folks inside Iran
um but you know there are the pockets of
connectivity and we are seeing footage
come out and again yesterday in zahadon
there were some incredible footage over
54 people ended up being arrested
everything
in Berlin also the sound of defiance
they've been accused by Iran's clerics
of being dreamers for believing in
change but there's determination here to
prove them wrong Sadia chowdry Sky News